yeah we're now live chat
right okay we'll start then good
afternoon everybody
um and welcome to anybody who's watching
us on youtube
you will have a a a fantastic meeting
and you'll all enjoy it um we'll get
down to business straight away
apologies for absence then who who's
doing us tom you
no mary's here pete oh mary's here is
she right
mary pete yeah apologies for encounter
tony inch
right okay uh
item two the minutes of the last meeting
everybody's read the minutes
uh could i have a proposal in secondary
please
simon suppose who's dude
yeah okay i'll just run through it
the sheets reach three
four five
six seven
seven oh that is for one meeting
that's the first meeting on tuesday the
15th of september
um we have a proposal and seconder for
that
could you do account mary
hello mary yes
did you do that chair are you taking the
boat on
minutes individually i was going to do
that just in case
anybody's got anything dublin okay okay
are we ready for the
15th of september yeah okay
about him four
councillor coddle honking for
mr dengate four
councillor gupp oh
councillor haines oh
mr harper paul
councillor langford or
councillor manley or
councillor newton or
and councillor watson oh
yeah thank you right we've got two
minutes of the 29th of september
proposal second day
simon newton second second
five seconds i'll just go through the
sheets play
seven eight
9 10
11 12
13
and 14.
okay um
can we can we do a count mary please yes
of course
cancel about them at four
mr harper or
councillor lanford or
councillor manly or
councillor newton or
councillor watson unanimous chad
okay thank you mary right um
item three action list page 15 and 16.
okay
69 that's still ongoing
minute eight seven to july 2020
that's completed
and
then minutes eight the seventh of july
that that is ongoing minute nine seventh
of july
to convene meeting of income generate
that's that's completed so
we'll move on sorry bye
hello wait a minute peter wait a minute
i haven't got my participants thing up
right okay yes go on peter what
oh sorry uh chair thank you um the
income generation meeting um
i'm not quite clear we're having a
report at this meeting about the ethical
investment discussion
that we had are we uh i think we're just
having an update from
steve steve you're going to give us a
bit of an update steve
um cheers and agenda item is agenda item
number nine
yeah um an update i'm the finance
manager okay
i know it'll be you david you're blessed
with that job now
right we'll move on
public contributions i don't believe
we've got any
i've not been told of any anyway
declarations of interest
uh you all understand about the
declarations of interest
so no need for you to read all that out
agent mata's brought up with the
permission of the chair i've got no
urgent matters
um agreements
item seven agreement of agenda spot one
and two
there's no part two um
and the dreaded thing now is qbr2 pages
17 to 38.
we need to agree the agenda
we no there's no way we need to agree
the agenda
there's agree of agreement of agenda
between sparks one and two we've got no
part two
sorry i thought we always voted on it
perhaps i'm wrong
part two
hello that's that's correct chair only
if there's a party
or any of his parts only if we've got
part two
that's pretty good check in just check
in oh yeah
thanks joe okay where were they
oh hey hi to me qbr
two i believe it is our good friend
david hayes is going to do this
that's correct um tom help me out is the
next slide the presentation
thank you okay okay so i want to just
update members on where we are
um in terms of the finances of the
council as at the end of september our
quarter two reporting
right if members recall at the end of
quarter one we actually projected a
break even position
and we're now projecting a surplus of
642
000 pounds but there's above
next slide please tom okay so what's
changed since last time
um it's suffice to say this is one of
the more interesting years in finance
i've ever worked
um and it's a very fast-moving pace
since we met last and we've had further
government support for covid
and this is both in terms of new burdens
but also
transfor uh funding
um planning income has exploded to be
perfectly truthful with you
yeah as of today there's more planning
income than the actual annual budget
um yeah um cost share which is the money
we get for
um our recycling which is um because we
by
we recycle more the county council put
less into landfill
we put an estimate in the end of last
year of what we'd get
we're only we don't see the full um
details of the contract so we can only
estimate
um we underestimated by 72 000 pounds
since then we've had staff vacancies of
207 thousand pounds and
the net slide actually gives up right or
the next slide after breaks that's in
more detail
um when we're looking to reopen our
leisure
facilities we know um asbestos was found
on torrent and pool roof
and they estimate cost of that adversely
this way going the other way at 65 000.
our income from our hostile income our
homeless hostels
um we're forecasting that to be 42 000
pounds below budget
mainly because we've reduced the
capacity at the hostels because of
covert restrictions
but also because we did delays in
actually renovating the site on the high
street
so actually came online later than we
predicted
and there's various other vacancy
various other variances which come to
the total of 642
000. i think probably what's important
at this juncture is
well it's to separate the impacts of
covid 19 on the council's finances
versus the business as usual variance if
we will always have variances
from budget just by the nature of the
beast but i just thought maybe
the important thing is to remember is
just to um i'd
um separate the kovid related items so
next slide please tom
so there's a slide there um there's a
column which is labeled favorable and
there's a column which is labeled
adverse and the net of it is 500 half a
million pound favorable
to torres district council
possibly very uniquely turret is one of
the very rare councils that's had a good
year financially from the pandemic so to
speak uh most of my colleagues across
devon that i speak on a reasonably
regular basis
the financial position is is completely
different in their firm
districts and councils so the central
government has given us
today four tranches of general coverage
support grants which amount to one
million one hundred and eighty seven
thousand
we've also had over covered new burdens
funded
for example the administration of the
business support grants
and they amount to 218 000
we'll also receive we will receive
compensation for our loss fees and
charges that only actually relate to
roughly 75 percent of the fees and
charges that we've lost
um unsurprisingly staff haven't gone on
a lot of training
because there's been unavailable okay
we've saved on transport related class
both members because
all these meetings are taking place
virtually rather than in the real world
and also staff haven't gone to as many
meetings
on the other side at the adverse well
quite clearly
the first three months of the year when
we're in a strip lockdown
our parking income essentially is nil
and that's three of our busiest months
the april may june period
it certainly bounced back and i'll refer
to that later
we've got reduced income from our
treasury deposits
we're literally getting we're doing well
to scrape anything above zero in terms
of our return on our treasury
deposits at the moment so we're taking a
big hit on that
obviously i've referred to the hostilink
and the reduced capacity and it come in
late on stream
court costs the council when we take
somebody to court for unpaid council tax
and if we're awarded the court cost they
amount to 60 pounds per case we've only
just started
taking recovery action i don't expect
this year
to achieve anything like the normal
court cost income that we normally
achieve so
that's why i'm showing as an adverse
variance
the contractual pressures have referred
to there of 181
are basically the leisure obviously
the world's changed a little bit since
then because we're now in a lot down and
our election facilities can't open up on
was it the second of november they were
supposed to open up by the fourth
november i can't recall now
december december december no sorry when
our leisure facility is supposed to open
up we're supposed to open up
so anyway that money that's uh you see
there is our
monies that we set aside for the
additional the close cost of um 1610 and
also
their additional running costs there's
been various other coverage
19 expenditure pressures such as ppe a
bit more agency backfill for people who
are self-isolated on the refuge
department
some expenditure within the it
department in terms of extra
laptops and equipment and zoom licenses
so we can all operate these meetings
and we're forecasting reduced cut income
from council tax and business rates of
336 000
but when you do the positives and the fa
and the adverse we're coming to half a
million favorable for the council
next slide please tom
um there is a brief summation it's
actually uh
i hope people can read it's quite small
on my screen um the business as usual
vacant
variances which are connected with the
covid related pandemic
and we've got staff vacancies over and
above our target with 207
000 however about seventy thousand of
that relate to the senior management
researcher
in terms of so you know when steve was
appointed the chief exec and then we've
gone and revisited the structure
and the delays in putting that in place
that didn't come into place on the first
of april so about 70 000
of that variance is really related to
the senior management researcher
um planning income as i've alluded to
just exploded we've never seen a year
like this
never been in all honesty the kosher
recycled income have already alluded to
and transport related
savings not connected with members got
not coming to council meeting not
connected with staff but more this is to
do with the refuge department
i think if members may recall in march
and early april fuel prices were very
low
that's because it was list any traffic
on the roads
and the fuel wholesalers had fuel
stocking up in their
storage tanks and had to sell at a
discount to get rid
so we've had low fuel costs and we've
for the benefit of that
um green waste collections and they've
gone up
as you see the little asterisks decide i
suspect some of the additional green
waste collections and the additional
take
up may may be related to covid
in that the um
waste depots were shut the recycling
centers were shut so people couldn't
take their garden waste in their car
for the first couple of months so there
may have been some additional take-up
directly related to that i cannot
quantify that and i don't believe
richard hayes in the
refuge department could quantify that um
obviously the repairs to torrential pool
have mentioned the legal and
professional fees
i think members will be aware about the
health and safety case that's ongoing at
the moment
and that's why we set those legal fees
aside
we previously at the last um qbr
when we reported to internal review and
scrutiny it was recommended we set
something aside for our property
maintenance
reserve and also to fund future
apprentices and there's other vacancies
over variances um so
i'd say there i got about 140 of it it's
just business as usual variances
there may be some components which are
related to covered but
not really easily quantifiable okay
next slide please tom
and the first line there projections
projections projections i'd probably
question why you're employing me really
um because in the 29th of june i told
you you're looking at a 1.5 million
pound deficit
and then on the 18th of august i told
you you're going to break even
and today i'm telling you there's a
surplus of 642
000. so i'm not somebody who's very good
at falsely in the future it would appear
um
i think what's important for members to
know it's a very fast moving environment
central government make announcements
about funding i'm not party to those
discussions at a ministerial senior
civil servant level
and it's so it's very difficult to bet
to bid it
when i was practicing the deficit um in
june at that point planning income was
low
and we had no building control no land
charges it is
combat with obeyance the planning income
i think land charges income
will bounce back and actually exceed the
budget this year we've got a backlog on
land charges because the
property market seems so buoyant locally
i think there are unique factors to
torridge
[Music]
i think the staycation has meant that we
bounce back on our car parking income
strongly with the lowest incidence of
covert 19
in england and one of the lowest within
the uk
and therefore i think there's some fraud
so we've had relatively insignificant
agency backfill for frontline staff
within
richard's area i think people have
recognized that if they're going to work
from home
why not work from home from a nice place
like north devon rather than somewhere
like um
manchester um rochdale for example
um so i think that's why the planning
income has gone through i think it's
also a timing of some big developments
just happens to have been timed at this
time
the buy and property market have alluded
to so we've actually got
a backlog now in land charges so i think
the land charges income is bouncing back
for now there's a relative stability of
our commercial income
our commercial income is all local we
haven't got
money's invested in large office blocks
outside of torridge
like some local authorities have um
at the moment we still seem to have
demand for our commercial tenants
for our commercial properties and the
last one and i really have no answer to
you on this one
we have seen an exceptionally low
increase in the claims for local council
tax support
that's not i have no explanation for
that if i'm perfectly honest
we've seen if you look at say october
this year compared with october last
year we
averaged just under two 000 working age
local council tax support claims
and with 50 more than this time last
year so it's an insignificant
increase and i have no explanation as to
why that is
next slide please tom there's a boat
well the bus says we've had a good year
for um this year financially but we
still got a very large
um capital program with an equally large
funding deficit
so the surplus i'm forecasting for this
year 642 000 is somewhat massed
by the capital shortfall i'm expecting 5
million pounds
uh and there are some potential dark
clouds on the horizon
uh next slide tree tom
just interesting i did these slides i
think maybe two weeks ago maybe three
two and a half weeks ago and when i did
these slides a second lockdown hadn't
actually been announced
and i decided not to change the size to
just show how the
the world changes so we do have a second
lockdown
we will get less parking income during
that time now
fortuitously the government will
compensate us for about 75
of that lost income but we've got to
anticipate now
at least a month maybe longer a parking
income being lower than anticipated
there's increasing incidence of kovid 19
within turret we start to hear of more
cases
so there's like to be some increased
pressure on the finance budgets as a
result of frontline staff having to
self-isolate
i mean if i self-isolate it just means i
have to work from home
however if somebody's been a refuge
driver and they have to self-isolate
they're not working and we have to get
agency staff in
um i've know how i've no idea how long
the cov19 restrictions will last
and therefore i don't look we don't know
what the future provisions say something
like leisure services will be going
forward
almost certainly going forward to be
more expensive than we've traditionally
enjoyed
um one would think increase unemployment
would lead to increased claims for local
council tax support as i said
we haven't seen that yet in turret we
just seem unique in many ways
[Music]
i don't know what the underlying
reduction in the resident car parking is
income is going to be because we know
that more of us are working from home
and our town centres once the visitors
aren't here
there'll be less people going into the
shops presumably i don't know what the
reduction in our car parking income will
be in the long term i think there will
be a long term underlying reduction in
our car parking income
at the this year has been completely
massed by the number of visitors that
we've had
and will our commercial income stay
robust at the moment
we don't have a problem filling our
vacant commercial
properties who knows if there's a much
deeper
recession okay next slide please tom
so we have a recommendation and that's
to recommend to community and resources
that the projected surplus identified at
642 thousand pounds is transferred to
the capital
reserves recognizing that the capital
program is currently underfunded
by circa 5 million pounds
is there any questions anybody got any
questions for david
uh yes please um who's that oh
simon tizzai uh
just uh david uh thanks for that very
clear um
you almost feel that uh this part of um
the meeting we should have been doing in
part two
because um as a fairly experienced crown
employee of
myself i would live in fear that
somebody is going to stretch down and
actually take money away from us
or at least next year if not this
if we crow about our very
um very favorable position which is
which
much of it has come about through your
good guidance but um
should we be a bit cautious about uh how
much we
um how well we say we're doing to
everybody
because um i i'm my experience tells
that sometimes it's just better to be a
little bit quiet
when things are looking good like that
and you you wouldn't want me to
do like you're less than clear and
honest with members surely um councillor
newton
no no no i understand we have um
in fairness you make a personal point
because we actually do monthly
returns on the financial impacts of
covid19
okay and we've been
i have had concerns and i have shared um
that we've got it on record
from the powers that be that this grant
is not ring fence and not going to be
clawed back
our monthly returns which we do to the
um
mcl mc lg yeah
i have to put down what we're spending
on
i can't and i can't in good faith as a
section one five one off to the council
and put things on that return that i
don't believe are truthful
i'm not suggesting
you say about this meeting being part
two what i'm saying is essentially this
information is being reported to
government on a monthly basis yeah
just okay is it okay if i add something
as well yes you can steve
and obviously david through the the
presentation also indicated the amount
of money
in terms of support for some of the
schemes that we've put in
i think it was somewhere around 200 000
now
that money is for additional things like
staff resource
to build these schemes that we've been
asked to do on a really really quick
basis
um so we haven't our staff have kind of
really stepped up to the mark
got everything um up and running
underway
um without us having to rely on
kind of getting in extra agency stuff
and things like that
now one of the things we are aware of
one of the things we've been dealing
with
is you know staff have been building up
extra hours they
not a lot of leaves being taken so some
of that will be reflected
in some other in that position as well
um now obviously if we just got out and
got agency staff in we would have
probably used a lot more
but we probably wouldn't have got
everything up and running as quickly and
as efficiently as we
have done without um kind of our staff
support and the hard work that's been
put in
so a lot of it a lot of that side of
things is down to that
um clearly as david's um alluded to
we've still got the best part of five
months
of this year uh left to go um
you will have all seen reported um
numerous occasions as david mentioned
the incidence level
levels are increasing and increasing in
torrent so
we do expect at some point probably
during the next
couple of months to have some staff
incidences or staff
self-isolation incidences where
particularly in the the waste and
recycling service we'll have to
back fill with agency staff um
what we don't know is whether there will
be any any further money or whether we
have to manage
through the rest of the year with what
we've got but
um by making this recommendation doesn't
tie
members in for to be used uh on capital
resources if we need to
uh reallocate it at another point during
the rest of the year then that can still
be done
okay that's fine steve anybody got any
questions for steve on that
before i go to that the blue hands
richard
you've got your hand up yeah to some
extent steve's partly answered the
question what it was i was interested
in the what in the savings on the um
with the staff vacancies um i was just
wondering
what work isn't being done as a result
of those vacancies
and is there some savings that could be
made there in the sense that do we need
to fill all those vacancies
if we're managing all right without them
as it were does that make sense
steve um david will probably know a bit
more detail but somehow that some of
those vacancies
are planned um in terms of some of the
uh david obviously alluded to the
management restructure so we've managed
with a couple of posts short this this
year because the restructure is
different
um some of those posts we've been
uh trying to recruit two
particularly in uh the property
procurement team adrian
redwood's team so we've had difficulty
recruiting there
and and that's pushed back some of the
plans and some of the projects some of
the work we would have
hoped to have achieved so we are still
attempting to recruit
to those posts um and as i said there
are some
posts within uh that figure
that we knew would become vacant we
wouldn't plan on
filling them so for example in housing
benefits the move to universal
credit um as caseloads
transfers to universal credit the case
load in our housing benefits team
reduces and they have kind of planned
changes and will be factored in a
savings to next year's budget so there's
a
kind of combination of a number of
factors
okay that go richard
that's fine that's that's fine thanks
thanks so much yeah
nick laws do you want to say something
oh
always always no just a very short
comment
in light of this sort of going out live
on youtube
i think for a counsellor to suggest that
we should keep quiet about things
openness is the word we are an open
council
and far from uh i'll take the chances
with the government picking on torridge
uh but our residents need to see the
well-managed budget here look uh
excellent job
thank you thank you check okay thank you
okay
anybody anybody else got did you want to
come back on that simon
i can't see your hand up okay yeah i
will very briefly just to
just to say that no i don't think it was
really centered said in that way
it was there was actually a certain
amount of tongue-in-cheek which i think
any anybody reasonably would have picked
up
um so i was more concerned about the
experience of
um whether we're at risk of of
um any clawback in the future and david
has answered that
uh that very very carefully thank you
very much
okay shirley just a quick one about the
explosion in planning is that are these
mainly big big projects um
and new estates etcetera or is quite a
proportion of it sort of private
planning applications
i think the simple answer is both yeah
there's been some significant large ones
but just the sheer volume
has been extensive i mean so much so
that i know that like
um planning support are really
struggling just to keep
up to support the planning officers so i
think it's been an explosion of people
maybe who have time on their hands and i
decided let's put that um planning
thing for an extension i've always been
thinking about doing and then i think
it's been also the
um larger commercial um developers
thank you this has never been i don't
think this has ever been known before
to expand explode like this i think this
is a unique year in many ways council
watson certainly on this planet because
the fact that we've exceeded our
planning budget
i don't think only in the first week in
november yeah it's probably
unprecedented
we've still got to go through to march
yes and god's truth
right okay peter ames yeah it's just
just commenting chair on the increase in
planning applications could it be
somewhat to do with the fact that we
haven't fulfilled our
five-year housing allocation
well i i could probably i i think it's a
little bit to do with it
i would think but not not a vast amount
to do with it
people are going for extensions like
david said
you know and and it's
it's just been well i mean
they're just overworked they're
overworked now in the planning
department to be quite honest
four or five more staff so steve and
david could look and see where we could
get the money from well we've got
642 000 so i'll tell sean arrington and
sean carney that yes you can have three
or four more people hey
yeah so you're not going with the
recommendations chair then
no yeah anyway
anybody else got any questions for for
for david and for steve before we go
through
go down and go through the um
questions and answers wherever i put it
no
no i mean talking about talk
one thing david talking about planning
i noticed that um uh in in adrian's
um little bit
designed to continue for the for the
wolves
are weird when when the planning apple
applicator's got to come in for
brunswick wolf because it said it said
november
i'm sorry i'd have to defer to
colleagues here i haven't i've got that
information sorry
yeah that's that's the latest
information we had from the applicant
that it would be november
right and is that is that for a full
application
um i'm not sure yeah because
that'll be a lot of money okay that's
fine okay we'll go through
the questions and answers now then okay
um okay what we'll do then is that well
page one um
first one page on page 19
but budget monitoring has everybody read
that one
put in by steve steve dengue
yeah can we have the questions on the
screen or not oh yeah i i would think so
uh yeah i'll see if i can get that one
second
oh
[Music]
mr chairman here we go
councillor hodson speaking could i just
interject
before you move on to this you haven't
taken a vote on
the previous agenda item oh okay
no sorry oh thank you thank you
what i was going to suggest i didn't
intervene i didn't know they may i was
wondering sometimes there's
separate recommendations come from this
information whether you want to take
it at that point or take them all
together it could be any further at the
end
yeah take it at the end if you like
that that'd be fine i i thought we were
going to do that but
okay right first question then
okay this is a verbal look this is a
verbal update from myself
yeah okay i'm sorry and
mr dengue's question um this is
difficult
uh when we set the budgets in february
2020 we look forward to assessing the
financial pressures facing the council
over the median term i.e up to 2024-25
and the medium-term financial strategy
in february projected a funding gap
for the year 2021-22
for 259 000. obviously being a forward
projection
there's many assumptions such as the
council tax increase the central
amount of central government ground pay
award inflation pension contributions
etc
and in terms of including it within the
qbr
generally this is the time of year now
that i start looking at revising
the term financial strategy because it
starts to tie in with the government's
um spending reviews
so it's i won't really know of any
indication of what central government
grant is going to be
until december so in terms of saying how
the budget for
how the to give some context to the
surplus this year in terms of next
year's budget
the best information i have until around
this time of year probably early
december
is what the median term financial
strategy said back in february so
i'm i'm i'm not entirely sure the
benefit
of updating essentially the forecast
every quarter because the big components
really won't become known until december
i don't know if i've made
does that make sense mr dengate of what
i'm trying to say no it does no
thanks david i think it was just if
there was a way of of kind of
getting more noticed time you know if
there were issues that if there's a way
of flagging it but
i can understand that you're you're kind
of beholden a bit to that time
sensitivity around
december to february so i mean the only
thing i could think of in context would
be that when we do this as we actually
show
what the last medium-term financial
strategy showed for the
financial year um that but that's going
to be quite out of date by that time
because it would have been what was done
for in february
and when we come to um quarter three and
we did monitoring at that point we would
have
have
a reasonable estimate of the budgets for
the year afterwards so maybe there would
be some context at that point but during
the year it just is really difficult to
do
and really difficult to make it very
meaningful i should say
i suppose it's trying to protect the
trend but we kind of
know where the trend is at the moment
anyway but it's just you know getting
that visibility if there was a way but
i recognize it's also tied to the
strategic plan so
obviously that changes then okay we
might have different monitoring
requirements but thank you okay thank
you
okay happy with that stephen thank you
yes
yeah we've gone to the next question
page 20 this has been put in by shirley
um our ttc likely to make car parking
free
uh we've got an answer there from sean
carter two answers from sean carney
um i'm i'm happy with those answers
i was just interested to know i know it
wasn't quite what what
is in the report because that's about
the charges but i was just interested to
know if there was any sort of
or might be any sort of rethink with
this second lockdown
i was also interested what um sean said
about the information available that
does not appear to have been any
positive increase in footfall for the
time it was in operation
which is quite interesting because
that's what i thought would happen but
um anyway no that's fine thanks very
much okay
thanks shelly peace too then
gonna move up one steve
tom page two
phase 21 uh this is
uh from ian arpa
um
sorry chair we've had this from david
hayes haven't we
i think he was sorry to interject there
counseling i think
mr harper was asking particularly why
one line at the top of the qbr was shown
what the
variance was on the strategic manager
services and i just gave him um
a breakdown of the things that are
contained there in within that
particular segment so i suppose
is a satisfactory answer mr harper
yeah that's fine thanks so much david
okay thank you
right okay um i think the next one on
investments is a verbal update from
myself
um david yes i'm i'm sure you're sick of
the sound of my voice um
the simple answer um mr dengue is yes
i can provide that and that's not and
too difficult
um and we if if members are minded we
can include this
in the qb answer just to give you some
context on the figures that you've got
in terms of the current investment
holdings
at the moment we've got 17 million
pounds
on short-term treasury deposits
these are as i've said before unusual
times
so to give some context as to why we've
got 17 million pounds
15 million of that is currently with
lloyd 2 million is with leads building
society
14 million of it is either with instant
access
or 32 day notice accounts three million
of it is due back in
january i can i if you want i'll
circulate this after the meeting a
little table which breaks it down for
members
yeah what's difficult at this moment in
time is if members are aware we got 34
million pounds at the start
of the pandemic to support business
support grants
we paid out approximately 27 million
pounds
we've been anticipating now for the last
best part two months the government
clawing back seven million pounds
um and they haven't done so so
i've got no indication that they could
just literally take the money
tomorrow okay so with that uncertainty
it's made it veg uncertainty on our
castle we've had to put a lot of stuff
into instant access because they could
give us very short notice period to give
back the seven million pounds
um to be honest the interest rates we're
getting at the moment are so low that
putting it away for three months
compared with having it in an instant
access it's such a marginal difference
in terms of
particularly when you take the treasury
management policy which is
um security liquidity and return being
the last priority
um we've also got notice that we're
going to get a further four million
pounds on friday for the next stand
the next answer the local lockdown
business support scheme
so my colleague peter hudson he's not
having an easy time at the moment
because it there's never been so much
cash flowing through the council's
coffers both in
and out to businesses and there's never
been so much uncertainty
of um suddenly grant funding appearing
so in terms of
it's difficult for us to put anything
away for any lend for time so
at the moment our investments
um are strange in that we've got so much
one with lloyd which breaches our
treasury
um policy which we announced at the
start of this week there's no way we
could actually operate without reaching
our treasury policy
but also how much we've got in very
short-term deposits
does that answer your question um mr
dengate
yes i mean i think it was i i guess that
there was money sitting there
was potentially not necessarily at risk
but was
was held because of the government grant
structure it's the clawback yes
yeah so i i because it's otherwise it's
kind of
trendy it's exceptionally higher than we
would normally expect but
i suppose it's the underlying element as
well that is
um more longer term our own
deposits that would be there that would
be of interest as well
as the money that's in government so
separating out the team
i understand yeah um so anyway i'll
circulate
um after this meeting a breakdown of
what
makes up the 17 million pounds which is
in the report
and then if members want to then i will
put this in the qbi on a regular basis
okay that's great dude anybody else
well just maybe in i was going to say
just maybe whilst
we're in this kind of climate of large
sums flowing through it
it might be good that we've got
visibility on that figure
okay yeah okay
[Music]
next question then page 23
this has been put in by ian
um sean carney has uh answered
all of them um everybody is everybody
happy with those answers
especially ian
yeah i'm fine thanks chad yeah the only
thing i do worry about sometimes
is the the focus that um how torrej
actually phase fares with the
um well with kovid and with businesses
um and do we have a strategy there
particularly for torridge
not particularly northern devon as a
whole right
do you want that question answering
sorry
i didn't catch part of it i think you i
lost a little bit of
what you said something about no uh
torridge as
it's in itself or i i think because the
very torridge is actually
um the way this the businesses are
structured in torridge
we've got very small businesses and
those are those those are the ones that
are probably particularly going to go
out of business
um and i what i don't see is anything
actually looking at
how we support torridge as opposed to
northern devon
um well i guess that the point is our
our torridge plans fit into north dakota
and then fit into the the wider devon so
there's a
kind of cascade structure so if you
think of
kind of some of the the recovery plans
we've got about discretionary
uh business rates and or business
support
we look at our own um
structure of businesses and apply
discretion based on the type of
businesses we have so we
we do build uh that into the context of
of our support
but we are somewhat comparable with
north devon and that's why we've been
working with or working we are working
with
north devon as a northern devon
economic area because that adds a
greater amount of weight
when we bid in for funding particularly
through the the lep
and kind of government departments
so that's kind of why we do it because
there's better opportunities
um and we do recognize our own
individual
needs that's why if you look at the
answer uh chris has been working
with particularly with the towns and
benefits great times and polls worthy
looking at specific areas of need there
okay all right
yeah thanks very much yeah right we're
going to page um
page 24 now another one from
mr arper
david aids finance manager
do you like these answers mr arpa
the one that really concerns me is the
fish stock right you look at it now
we're actually going to be a hundred
thousand pounds
um at the end of the year short and yet
this is supposed to be a business
contraction
uh contract with with with other people
um
can we still afford to that sort of um
finance david
unmute david
apologies when you say a hundred
thousand pounds mr
are you including the one with the um i
can't actually see it on my screen could
you just
move the screen down for me tom thank
you uh are you including the one with
the um recharge is that what you're
referring to mr harper yeah in other
words treating it took as a cost center
which that is yeah
yeah you would not you're right in terms
of when we apportion our
overheads to the council that'll be a
proportion of the property services team
a proper
proportion of finance provision hr what
all the various components of support
services
then yes um it wouldn't um break even
with those charges
added too but then we if the fish stock
went to model we wouldn't save those
charges anyway so that's why
on a personal phase action which always
concentrate on the cash that comes in
and the cash
comes out but i think you're right that
and the fish stock
we had to take on the fish stock when
the the previous um
collective that ran it folded um
and i think this may be a judgment for
the council isn't it in terms of
it's not a pure commercial undertaking
we do
some activities which are for an
economic regeneration
basis i can't argue at the moment that
this is a
um in strictly even intricately cash
terms a
um profitable enterprise
okay ian okay
yeah i think it's something we should we
should as used as david said we should
be looking at perhaps as a
as a scrutiny right okay
right should we move on then
are you happy with them with them
answers there then in
that's fine thank you yeah okay page 27
and 28
this one's been put in by by shirley
um yeah basically i was just interested
to know
because on previous reports i think
where there had been delays it was said
that sometimes it was because of southam
so i was just interested to know why
it didn't appear that southampton was on
this report
but um that's fine um but also
i think i'm pleased that it says that
the intention is to bring this service
back in-house as soon as we're able to
which
um going on what i've heard so far i
think is probably a good thing
um thank you okay thanks shirley
jay if you if you just want me to i i
answer that one then in
in response to bring it back in
household um
just for members information we are
currently advertising for the staff
resource
which would then enable that to take
place so
uh recruiting currently
okay that's great thank you right page
2728
mr arpa um are you happy with
the answer you you've been given there
i think it's a full answer and thanks
very much yes thank you
right next page
okay page 28 shelly again
no that's that's fine thanks very much
okay
who is that uh councillor holmes peter
james
all right
[Music]
reporting on this will be captured when
the new strategic plan is incorporated
into the qbr
so what when will that be so sometime
early next year will it
jf i respond responding to that so
uh i think i think john walt was on the
call so john and i had a meeting
this morning um to discuss
uh this and many other pieces of work in
the strategic plan so
um what we at the next full council
we'll be bringing back
the uh rest of the consultation comments
if you recall when i
uh when the leader and i uh reported the
strategic plan there were a number of
consultation
items outstanding um what we then
planning to do is put together what will
be a delivery
plan for some of those bigger items in
the strategic plan
and the housing one is obviously a
significant
piece of work um so the the leader and
i've had
um a meeting with the chief executive of
westwood housing
we've also met with paul clark from the
lga
starting to investigate uh options for
pulling this
substantive piece of work together so
jay will report back at the next full
council um
how that will develop right okay well on
monday
um sorry not not monday the next one in
december the next schedule for
full time so meet them okay steve
okay uh next question then
uh page 28 29 another one from mr harper
answered by sean arrington ian are you
happy with that
yeah i think that's fine as i say the
only thing is that um as i think it's
been raised by some members in the past
about some of these p planners or no
planning but
some of the builders not actually um
how can we phrase it and the nicest way
uh
you haven't been economical with the
truth perhaps
yeah well it's very difficult to make
builders
developers build
yes peter yeah um just comment it's a
bit sort of contradictory this response
isn't it
um likely to result in major residential
applications like the result an increase
of affordable and then at the end it
says
due to the viability um arguments it
could reduce the amount of affordable
so i mean that's it in a nutshell in
that really
yeah i mean i think in this new white
paper that we've just
been consulted on i think that talks
about
viability if i remember right
yeah about yeah assessing viability
right at the beginning
we should go but kind of continue with
the viability
only time will tell with that anyway you
want to lousy lousy system basically
yeah right then we'll move on
uh base 28-29 here we go again shirley
um yeah um i was just it was just an
observation really that i felt
definitely round here in the first
lockdown anyway the construction site
seemed to me
the majority of them did shut whereas i
know elsewhere in the country
they definitely didn't um people didn't
want to commit
elsewhere they were worried about losing
money or being sued later on down the
line and big construction sites just
didn't shut and they weren't forced to
but it was just an observation really
thank you okay next one then
28 29 mr arpa
arri ropa's uh performance and
communications officers
has done this um answer are you happy
with that
well we will wait for other um figures i
believe
but uh yes it was just ours was so
dramatic
and i just wonder what the others in the
other parts of the country
were they experiencing similar drops um
i think it's pretty much country wide
oh david h david sorry david i miss your
aunt go on mate
yes i mean um we
didn't really have much construction for
three months so that's led into the
reduction in the tap space and also we
had an increase in our long-term empties
maybe because people weren't
switching accommodation as quickly as
they would normally
i've got a meeting with section 151
officers on
friday across devon and one of the
things we'll be discussing is actually
the council tax base so i may be able to
get some information from a separate
source on friday rather than
whatever contacts harry's emailing i may
be able to get it from a different
source if i do
by all means share it with members but i
suspect
there will be within the an impact of
the slowdown in the construction within
eight from april to june
i think that will impact most councils
yeah
yeah okay
ian okay yeah fine thanks very much chet
okay right page 30 and it's uh
you again shirley oh look i'm shirley
langmead there
that's good isn't it change i've changed
i was just concerned because it was in
that it was red whether anyone had
suffered as
any you know members of the public had
suffered as a result of this but
obviously as they don't appear to have
been any complaints i assume
i assume that it was all okay thank you
okay also watson there is a
supplementary answer to that that joe
wells the reps and bend managers
provided
do you want me to just i did speak to
her this morning just so because i
didn't understand the answer of him
being perfectly honest so just
maybe i've got it fresh from the horse's
mouth so to speak
yeah yeah so some of these delays um
in some ways there's somewhat technical
delays rather than real delay so what
happened was at the start of the
pandemic
the government um enhanced the local
housing allowance
so say for argument say the local
housing allowance
was pounds for a three-bedroom property
for argument site
and then the government increased the
local housing allowance to say 600
pounds for example
that announcement our software provider
capital had to actually work through
that and change the underlying software
okay and then they had to test it and
then there was issues with testing so
that's the delays
but for the individual concerned they
were already the
previously they received 575 pounds and
they maybe paid 25 pounds out of their
own
resources towards the rent the situation
didn't change
it just meant that they had to wait to
get the extra 25 pounds so they were
it's not like a new claim and people
were waiting to get paid
it was an existing person who was
possibly entitled to slightly more
um housing benefit and had to wait to
get the slightly enhanced housing
benefit
they would have been prior to the first
whenever the change came in at the end
of the financial year prior to that
they would have to have been paying 25
pounds towards their rent
and it just meant we didn't give them
the 25 pound extra for eight weeks
so yes it was unfortunate but perhaps
not maybe quite the
crisis that would be if it was an
eight-week delay
say for a new benefit hopefully i've
explained that
yeah no okay thanks very much yeah
okay happy with that then shirley
yes thank you right uh goal number three
um page 31 this is from peter aims
um can't see the answer at the moment
[Applause]
um well it starts there regarding item
three
yeah the point of my question for number
one was just to find out
really what um sort of discussions take
place with the county about
how how recycling could be improved
really but
um i think richard does does have
meetings with the with county doesn't
they yeah
have you read the the the answers from
richard hayes
yeah i was commenting on chair yeah um i
should just yeah they'll
take the opportunity here that there is
uh a waste county waste strategy
consultation out at the moment
so i does this council normally
um provide comments on that
can i can steve say or someone
steve um i'm sorry i was just struggling
with my mouse to get the the
mood off um as far as i know yeah so i
know
richard and councillor leathers the lead
member
have regular county-wide um
waste management meeting so yes i'm
fairly certain that
any um responses are provided
i meant it is there an opportunity for
councillors to input do we have it on an
agenda at all
um or is it up to individual councillors
to respond um shall check
if you appear on the action list then we
can check with richard haste
thank you yeah just on on the answers to
question two i mean my point is that
a huge amount of waste not just at
christmas but things like halloween
and i i assume it's the remit of our
council to encourage reuse
and uh reduction of waste as well as
recycling so
i mean hopefully it's good that that
we're putting things on the website
so it's not just christmas it's other
sort of um
other occasions in the year when there's
a huge amount of waste as well
and just to encourage people to um
stop wasting stuff really
thank you okay go for
this it's from you again shirley page 36
um yeah it was just it was just for
information really
that that that was um i know that that
has been said about the search is taking
so long and i know
steve mentioned something in his last
update to us about the huge pressure
that's on the department that do the
searches
but it didn't it the wording
of this information that came out it did
say that although
many local authorities are having
problems with it but it did say
um in particular torres district council
not it wasn't problems with it but that
they were taking a lot of time to get
searches done
um and it did say at least eight weeks
in particular torres district council
which i thought well i just thought
people ought to know that that
that's um being said
thank you okay stacy's on the call i can
provide
an update stacy sent an email like
a while back about all this work that
you've gotten didn't you
yeah i i i did and it's been ongoing for
for some time and actually
we've already discussed today about the
um exponential increase in planning
um land charges um feeds through the
planning team because a lot of the
inquiries
um that go out included in the land
charges result
are planning inquiries um
uh we have had a significant increase
um 70 increase in land charges last
month
40 this month 10
june july another 10 i haven't got the
figures for this month but
the we are absolutely inundated and
um i i think i don't think it's unique
to torridge i think devon and cornwall
as a whole
have received vast increases
in in property purchases and for the
obvious reasons i think you know we have
a lot of second home owners down here
um during lockdown period people have
realized that they can work here as well
um and you know i'm having reports from
estate agents that people are purchasing
properties without even viewing them
um it's not an easy one to
to easily resource because it's not a
situation where i can just
take um people from other teams because
the training behind it
is significant as well as the planning
team
um so the staff within both teams
are working overtime um but we can only
get
so many out the door and i think
um from our perspective there are delays
and i
i can't deny that and we've got quite a
significant turnaround it's it's 30 days
at the moment
but those delays aren't just from
torridge i i think
if you'll speak to solicitors and estate
agents they are also
inundated um it's it
really is unprecedented times i think
we've got increased demand on our normal
everyday services at the same time as
having
um new demands put on us um and i think
all i can say is we're doing everything
we can
um to try and reduce the backlog as
quickly as as we possibly can
um but i mean david when we had
discussions when we were trying to
set the budget going forward and david's
comment to me at that stage was where
you're never going to catch up with your
land charges income
but again um if we look at the budget we
are
on budget to exceed um what we ever
um thought we were going to and i think
we didn't anticipate such an increase
but it's happened and we're having to
deal with it
so i think it's very easy to point the
finger at torridge i'm not going to deny
that there are delays but all i can say
is we're doing everything that we can to
try and turn it around as quickly as we
possibly
can but the staff are working
evenings weekends as well um
and yeah i can't i can't
do we can't yeah it wasn't it wasn't a
criticism by me at all oh no
i i just thought you ought to know that
that
was being said and um you know
equally i also know that solicitors are
saying that they
are in l as you say they're inundated
and
overloaded with work and so things are
taking longer from their end as well as
you said
but it was it was really just for
information and yeah
no i think you know it wasn't taken as a
criticism but i thought it was handy
just to try and explain the background
to
all um you know and try and give give
some context to the situation and um
like i said i don't think people do
realize that
when we're doing the searches we need
input from devon county
from planning from building control and
of course they're the teams as well
that that are inundated um with work in
addition to land charges so
we're we are trying to do our mo and i
know i suppose the message to the public
like
i think we did do a press release going
back a couple of weeks ago was
you know please bear with us we're
trying to do everything we can
um because we you know appreciate
especially with the stamp duty holiday
that people are going to be very very
keen obviously and working for them you
know
to to get the sale and purchase free
before the stamp duty kicks back in
again so um i think we're saying you
know
look we're aware of the delay try and
call us as little as possible
um because we are working on it you know
and monitoring it
you know well daily i'm you know at the
moment
so okay thank you
any more questions
uh do i think we should go back to the
recommendation first
where are we
john yeah i'm just gonna check this out
sorry
here we are okay
you you can all read that you've all
read that could i have a proposal in
second of them
who i stick right simon newton proposes
nearly like langmead or langford
seconded it could you go to the vote
mary
hello yeah all right
councillor guppy or
councillor haynes or
mr harper or
councillor langford or
councillor manly for
councillor newton for
councillor watson
hey unanimous thank you so that will go
to
the next next cnr no maybe not
okay item nine then review of treasury
investment options
verbal update finance manager and
interim section 151 officer
god's truth you're working getting in
your money today mate
thank you um so
following on i must admit forgive me i
can't remember it was at the income
generation group or the last um
internal over scooter we discussed
ethical investment and uh my colleague
peter hudson was tasked with
doing a little bit of investigative work
in it yeah
so um i think a company called an
organization called
tridos council james will correct me if
i pronounce that incorrectly
yeah try doors okay so duncan's
investigating that's a dutch bank
recently set up a uk subsidy
and at the moment that is unrated by
fitch
so if you remember our uh council's um
treasury management policy that
we can only invest in um financial
institutions which are fitch one
um rated yeah um we also
have to think by counselling to look at
the cooperative bank as well
and they currently have a rating of b
and we're not so that's like below the
level that we would
our treasury management policy would
allow us to um
invest however we've looked at some
green deposits with barclays standard
charter and our own lloyds bank
and they have green deposits okay
and they're not too dissimilar to the
interest rates we would get for just
having money on
32-day notice account or 95-day code
account
so just looking at the detail of the
lloyds
green account this it's called the
sustainability
95-day account and their policy states
that this would
seek to invest in energy efficient real
estate lending where its commercial
properties including office industrial
retail hospitality and university
campuses building
obtained it was a minimum brie hang on
bream
very good i'm going to just get my
glasses on because i can't read
which obtain either minimum of bream
which is very good provide a minimum of
70 percent is achieved in the energy a
category or epc
rating of b or highest essentially
investing in energy efficiency buildings
or residential properties which have an
e-piece
or higher they also this they would
invest in renewable energy for
properties in the uk and
abroad which would be offshore wind
farms onshore wind wind farms
solar energy and tidal energy
and they would also lend to small and
medium enterprises located in the 30
most economically disadvantaged areas in
the uk
and lending to health care providers
located in the 30 percent most
economically disadvantaged areas in the
uk
so what we're saying is we could if
members were so minded
invest in our sa call accounts within
our
lloyd's 95-day account where we call
their suspense
substance and i can't get my teeth in
sustainability lending and management
criteria which as i've alluded to
is energy efficiency renewable energy
small and medium
enterprises in the most economically
disadvantaged areas
so to do obviously to move forward on
that we'd have to
make a slight tweak to our treasury
management policy
um the lloyd's green account the
barclays green account the stat standard
charter green account
they still got the fixed f1 rating so
that's not an issue
but it's um recognizing that we may
put money in that which may have a
slightly lesser rate of return
than if we just did it in the standard
um short-term investments
so anybody got any questions
uh chair yeah yeah
well thank you for that um i mean it
would be helpful if we had
it actually in writing so okay um
i mean i don't know where we go from
here whether you have to make a
recommendation but
it's difficult if we haven't got the
material in right
i mean i can share with you councillor
haims um
the fact sheet relating to the lloyd's
account
yeah or maybe or maybe the
recommendation could be
to well ultimately we've got to change
our
um treasury management policy which
would say that we with this
there's an acceptable loss for one of a
better word if we invest in a green
account okay and i think uh my colleague
peter's defined what he
would say would be an acceptable loss
which is like point two of one percent
in terms of the rate okay at the moment
to be honest with you
there's very little difference between
any of the accounts the green account
or a normal account in terms of the 95
day
notice so is it perhaps best if i
um circulate something following from
this meeting and then oh we perhaps we
david yes
i think what was agreed at the working
group was that we would provide
a general verbal update at this meeting
today
provide more detailed information
at a working group after this formal
meeting
with a view then of bringing a report
and consider any subsequent
recommendations
at a formal committee meeting obviously
you haven't got a report today so you
can't make a recommendation
um that would be done at the next
18 and that could then be taken forward
if necessary
into the report for the treasury
management strategy for next financial
year
so that was the kind of intention
of the working group process
like sorry chip oh he's gone i think for
december our next meeting
so they got it scheduled on the forward
plan for december to
for the working group to come back and
we would
make that part of the the document that
comes to the recommendation
yeah sorry i'm not so we're not having
an um
working group meeting between now and
then scrutiny then it would go
your report now we are that peter
we'll go to we have a meeting with the
working group
on the yeah the second or the third of
december
yeah so it goes to the that meeting then
the report
is that we'll take on the 15th
of december we've got the meeting yeah
just
just to uh um i'm slightly surprised
that we don't get any
any sort of notes or minutes from the uh
in the um income generating group really
because
i can only remember some of what we
discussed i know i recommended certain
banks but it would be useful if we had
just some short notes from the from
you know those income generation
meetings really
right some short notes for when you go
to the next meeting
yeah just so we know what we discussed
not put out widely
um well i'm all for transparency yeah
they should go out generally but
um we can't just rely on us remembering
what happened at a meeting
we would have we would have notes on the
day that we're there
we would know what what was said the
date when we left of the next meeting
yeah we make our own oh see normally we
have notes taken at a meeting don't we
by
by an officer but that's all i'm saying
but um
okay all right okay peter and david will
have taken notes
from the the instructions from the
working group and that's what david is
now
reporting back on we said we would
have a follow-up working group meeting
between this meeting and in time for the
working group to consider
what to include in a report to the this
scrutiny committee
yeah yeah but the members didn't get the
notes did they
the people at that meeting i can't
remember seeing any notes
thank you that's that would be useful to
have
am i making myself clear sorry
just a record of the meeting chair
hudson
okay all right
right is that i've
anybody any questions for for david or
steve
no
okay okay item 10 then
consideration of forward plan
on page 39
[Applause]
right
right
forward plan then okay
sure um
in regards to the budget um this is
probably more questions
david um i mean we've discussed this i
think before but
and without kind of creating work
unnecessarily are we able to kind of
highlight
the um statutory the discretionary in
the blurred areas
in some way in the budget be it in some
kind of form of color coding or just
helping us to
to differentiate between the the core
council's expenditure and those areas
that perhaps are
you know more from the discretionary
side is that something that we can build
within the budget or is it
it's sort of too hard to to do that
it's it's not without its challenges
because there'll be
certain things are more easily
identified so you know for example
the grant that we pay to the burton is a
discretionary
yeah but other budgets
um staff literally a
individual will do some functions which
is statutory and some function to a
child statutory
um and so it and it's also quite an
undertaking for us to do that
if i'm being i'd be reluctant to do it
and being perfectly honest
because of the effort too and there's
also the
you'd need a lot of caveats to it
because um
you might look at say the um parks
budget
and certain thing in most of our open
public spaces are non-statutory but
there will be elements of um
statutory functions within that
within those departments so that's it
it's a difficult job i know you've asked
before uh mr deng
and we've managed to avoid it i know
i i i'm not looking to put you all under
more work you've got more than enough on
at the moment probably not the best year
to ask no
i know but that's because i asked
previous years yes i know read it in
advance
um but more that as we get into the the
difficult terrain of
looking at the capital programme
and and the difficult areas of where we
have to make decisions
um it might help people if they have a
better understanding of which areas are
in that discretionary category so
i i don't know i leave it to ponder on
but if there was a way to
i i agree there's areas of growing it
and
it's not straightforward it's not black
and white but there is an element of
black and there is an element of white
and there's
maybe we can just focus on something
that helps us
discern okay yeah i would probably add
that it would probably be as david said
something that
something to look at next year rather
than this year because
um the team are under immense pressure
to get a hell of a lot done in a very
short
time frame um so you know i
kind of stress that this year definitely
is the right year
to be looking at that level of detail um
but if the the committee wanted to do
something during next year then
you know that has a greater level of
potential and
the level of details david's had to be
quite a lot of work and you need to make
sure you get it right otherwise you
might be
seeking to take decisions or make
recommendations
that really need to have all that
underlying detail
um really really accurate no i recognize
that it's
it's it's just a form of scoping
exercise and it maybe also would help
give a bit more focus to people to on
the the top line
as much as the bottom line so
all right anything else
stephen
that's that's fine i think we're getting
the the answer
that um maybe we mustn't lose sight of
the fact that it's a piece of work that
at some point
will be informative but i recognize the
constraints for this year
um but maybe as a committee we need to
keep focus on that
yeah okay steve right sometime or other
we're gonna have to look at the
uh have a bit of a review of the capital
program as well
because you know we've got money
well we've got things in that we ain't
got money for
so something sometime or other we
probably have to have a look at that
steve
okay that piece of work is underway
um so um next week you've got a
property major projects working group
and that will be the start of that
process
right um then there'll be a report to
cnr
and a report
well you as a scrutiny committee then
look at any recommendations that come
out
from um cnr as you would ordinarily do
as part of the budget process
right okay so where when when what cnr
meeting will that go to then
seven for december i believe oh seventh
through december
yes because
on the 7th of december then we could
look at it in
at ons on the 15th of december then
that's why i went mentioned each year so
it would be timely to add to the
yeah that's fine today yeah we'll
we'll add that to to to 15th of december
then
yeah yeah
yeah you know when we've got down future
review estuary strategy
do we know when that's going is that
being revised or
what is that what what have we got peter
at the estuary strategy is that being
revised it's in the future review here
on the
plan
at the bottom here presentation of the
estuary strategy
is that you see that
okay that would be something for the
harbour board
yeah to consider in his first instance
and if there is an estuary strategy
for um you to consider if you still wish
yeah okay i think there's one two things
happening with the are barbaric them
innocently
i think there is anybody else
anybody else want to put anything on the
forward plan
didn't mention that we perhaps should
look at the
fish dog yeah so man yeah we're gonna we
can put that down
for a future meeting yeah
okay are you are you taking all this
down mary
is she gone mary
yes john taking it all down okay thank
you
okay anything else
chair chair it's john yes john john
um what do you want to put on the
forward plan
yeah um we i spoke to steve house today
um about a review of the qbr um
in line in line with the new strategic
plan
that's been adopted okay so mate so
maybe you'll want a a small working
group
to to um to work with officers to look
at that and then bring something back to
the um
yeah to the committee okay
yeah we can have a look at review the
qbr
i mean the qbr's nothing like what we
what it used to be
crikey um okay yeah we can we can
organize um
um a group to do that
can't we but when
sometime in the new year chair yeah yeah
so really we could we could look at
forming a task and finish groups uh
in the at the december meeting
yeah that'd be great okay thank you
yeah let me find it anybody got anything
else then
no okay okay in that case then um
thank you for all those people that are
watching on youtube
you've totally enjoyed yourself this
afternoon and
we will now be closing the meeting at
15 25.
thanks tom
i